when it comes to fitness the word
functional is one that is severely
overused I'm gonna share with you today
there an exercise that really is
functional in every sense of the word
walk with me okay so the suspense
probably didn't really work there seeing
as the name of the exercise is most
likely in the title of this video as you
already know I'm talking about loaded
carries but we might not know is exactly
what a loaded carry is or just how many
benefits there are to this exercise so a
loaded carry simply means that you're
carrying something and then go into a
walk and it's up to you how you carry
this thing there's lots of different
versions of the loaded carry but of
course you can invent your own and the
idea is simply to move a really heavy
object from one place to another and
that's why this is the most functional
exercise in loads of ways because it's
something that we actually do in real
life
when you carry shopping bags home from
Tesco that's a loaded carry when you
move furniture that's loaded carry and
it's also moved that any superhero
workout should include singers this is
one of the key moves of the superhero or
action hero is to lift the damsel in
distress or the bloke in distress out of
the burning building and look all heroic
doing it that's harder than it looks
even if you've got quite a light partner
there's a bunch of different types of
loaded carry the most popular one that
people might be familiar with is the
farmers walk and this is where you've
got a big heavy weight in either hand
dropped down by your side and basically
we can do this by holding two dumbbells
one in each hand or two shopping bags as
we said two tubs of paint whatever using
a trap fires quite a good way of doing
it this trains tons of stuff it trains
your traps of course and actually it's a
good idea to maintain a slight to trap
flexion so a minor shrug so your
shoulders aren't too depressed whilst
you're doing it it also trains your core
because you're keeping yourself upright
you're using both the ABS at the front
and also your posterior chain to keep
yourself nice and upright whilst you
walk it trains your balance as you're
walking along trains muscle endurance a
whole amount it trains your grip
strength tons and actually if you think
about it when you're carrying shopping
or when you're carrying furniture the
grip is one of the first things that
gives out so this is a great way to
build that kind of endurance and it can
even fix your gait when it comes to
walking when it comes to running this is
something they do for some runners
loaded carries is great way to fix your
biomechanics of the way you run so tons
of benefits there you're using all these
stabilizing muscles in your core in your
forearms in your legs that often don't
get a look-in
and this is fantastic and your hips in
particular this is great training for
your hips and this again prevents you
from falling over gives you more balance
you can improve your jump height and
it's just something that a lot of people
don't do that maybe they should be doing
and then there's the tons of different
variations on this move each of which
trains different things in different
ways you've got your Zurcher carry which
is where you carry it like a search of
squat so you're clasping your hands
together and carrying a barbell in the
crook of your elbow you have an overhead
carry which is where you're carrying
either one weight or two weights
overhead you can do it with one hand or
two hands so you can do a kettlebell you
can do a barbell you have your goblet
carry where you holding something like a
goblet squat such as a big heavy
kettlebell you have your suitcase carry
where you're carrying something in one
hand on one side bare carry where you're
grasping something towards your chest
whether that's a weighted sandbag or a
bag of cement whatever you like and all
these different variations will of
course slightly change the muscles
you're targeting also the challenge so
for
the suitcase carry because you're on one
side you've got to it's an anti lateral
flexion exercise meaning that you've got
to stop yourself bending to one side so
this really turns it into an exercise
for the obliques because the other side
is preventing you from bending in that
direction too much then when you have
the weight in front of you you're using
your posterior chain more for the same
reason to keep yourself upright so
you're not bending forwards and this is
great for fixing a lot of the problems
that we caused ourselves by working at
the computer because we're leaning
forwards and stretching forwards and up
or posterior chain gets all stretched
and weak and it's why many of us hunched
over so this is great way to fix that so
using different variations like that can
do a world of good and then you can
introduce more variations on top of that
so for instance another way you can use
a front loaded carry is to use a pinch
grip and hold two plates together so you
grab two weight plates pinch them
together and then you're using your grip
to squeeze those weights together and
prevent me from slipping through so now
it's not only gonna be great for your
core stability and your endurance but at
the same time you're training your grip
and like I say when it comes to these
kinds of functional movements that we do
in real life the grip is often the thing
that gives out first that's a great
option I said earlier that you could do
shrugs at the same time whilst you're
walking there's no reason why you can't
do curls although you'll find actually
that many of the front loaded carries or
a great isometric hold
on the biceps as well anyways I was
reading about this one guy cost
Ziya to xuer something like that a boxer
apparently who would sometimes as a form
of training pick up a kettlebell and
then just carry it for an hour so he'd
just go about his usual routine or he'd
do some kind of workout and at the same
time he's just carrying this kettlebell
the whole time and apparently this guy
had fantastic core stability and
strength and power and his punches as
he'd imagined he probably had insane
muscle endurance because well try it
it's incredibly difficult but this is a
great form of incidental training
there's no reason that you couldn't pick
up a kettlebell I say start with
something fairly light ish and then do
your unload your dishwasher and that's a
fantastic way to get a little bit of
endurance training whilst doing
something that's normally quite mundane
and boring so again get creative with it
you can go up or down stairs but sure
we'll say is potentially dangerous so be
really careful doing that you can turn
them into lunge walks in order to turn
it into a leg workout there's tons of
different options so the best way to
approach it is to use a whole different
bunch of them to use different
combinations and your workouts and that
way to really train that core stability
and this is the kind of stability that
make you harder to push over better at
wrestling it will improve your squats
and your deadlifts because you'll just
feel more stable and in one spot you're
less likely to injure yourself when
running because again more stability or
less like to fall over will improve your
balance and all of this is just great it
also builds muscle endurance like I said
and that's great for your work capacity
it's great as a finisher at the end of a
workout just to really test your
endurance your muscle endurance and
cardio to an extent this is a great form
of resistance cardio and that then means
that you can lift more as you build up
your work capacity you can lift more
increase your volume increase your
intensity and thereby training yourself
to not experience fatigue and not
experience overtraining as quickly it's
great for testing the nervous system in
terms of how heavy you should go and how
many sets and reps you should do if you
want to get the most benefits that all
depends the main thing the most
important thing is just that you're
progressing in some way and that's
something else that's fun about the
loaded carry because there's several
different metrics that you can try and
improve on you can lift heavier weight
you can walk further or you can try and
complete the walks more quickly and
again there's different ways you can mix
it up if you want to change your
training sessions so you can just as a
finisher at the end of the workout you
go for distance one time you can go for
speed another time or you could move
weights across the gym and you'll be
even more annoying for everyone else in
there but get a pile of weight plates
pick them up carry them to the other
side and again this is a really
functional to the kind of exercise you
might actually have to do something
similar to in the real world the key
thing is to make sure that when you're
lifting that weight that you keep your
body in a good straight upright position
if you're bending over too much then
that means that you're not being able to
counter the weight and that could
potentially cause more damage than good
and it's not beneficial so it's better
in that case to go slightly lighter and
then walk further or walk for longer and
to drop it once you start to find it too
heavy
negative is to take relatively short
steps if you take larger strides then
you're spending longer with your center
of gravity and your knees not nicely
aligning so take small steps forwards
and that way you're also less likely to
fall over which would be a really bad
thing however you do it give it a go
because it's something different and
that's again the main thing just trying
something different is always fantastic
for building more strength and stability
and making a body more adaptable and
improving your overall performance so I
hope you found this video useful
interesting if you did then please
consider leaving a like please share it
around please comment down below let me
know what you think or if there are any
other cool training techniques that
you'd like me to look into because
that's what I love to do if you'd like
to follow me on social media then I'll
leave my Instagram and my Twitter and my
facebook links down in the description
follow me on Instagram if you want to
see my workouts and my when I post new
videos etc that's where I'm most active
thanks a ton for watching and stay tuned
if you want to see more on bodybuilding
fitness martial arts productivity
technology all that usual stuff that
sounds good then thanks a ton for
watching and bye for now